VW's cross up is the beefier brother of
the up at first glance it's striking
offroad look suggests good handling in
an SUV class the regular up has been out
since 2011 now it's gone cross country
as the cross up but it's it really
possible to turn a city car into an
off-roader car tester Amano says from
the inside he sees no real difference to
the regular up but from the outside he
does a little the cross up features such
difficult
details as front and rear chrome
finished aprons the chassis has been
raised by some 15 millimeters clearly
defined side skirts make for a dynamic
SUV look the honeycomb grille is
dominated by a plastic cladding and the
sin on headlights give the cross up an
adventure as air also new are the
standard roof rails to what purpose were
these changes made Elfie Cour a
Volkswagen explains that like the up the
cross up is designed for the mini car
segment which she expects to grow in the
coming years along with the market for
off-road vehicles and optically VW's
cross up is following the trend but
aside from its conspicuous design the
cross up remains a city car it's three
cylinder gasoline-powered engine is the
only one available
it achieves 55 kilowatts of power and a
top speed of 167 km/h fuel consumption
is low at 4.7 liters per hundred
kilometers
that's father Mottola says the cross up
hardly differs from the regular up it
only smooths out the bumps a little
better but without sacrificing any of
the driving pleasure it's nice and zippy
and it feels good the cross up can
handle some rough terrain it's greater
clearance lets it move easily off the
asphalt but it's not a whole lot more
adventurous than that no expeditions
into the Australian outback for instance
but it can hold its own unreasonably
level ground
in spite of its name the cross sub cuts
a stylistically harmonious and confident
figure the dashboard painted the match
the trim frames neatly arranged switches
the generous air vents reinforced the
designs modern and sporty tendency
our car tester sums up
in schism this time the whole the cross
up is well done of course all the
plastic outside and 15 millimeters extra
clearance do not make an off-roader but
it is definitely suitable for dirt roads
and forest tracks the new more rugged
design will cost about 4000 euros more
than a comparable regular up in Germany
the cross up starts at just under 14,000
euros but a GPS system and AC will add
about a thousand euros to the price